[Music]
this is scooty he's a Californian
two-spotted octopus and he lives at the
University of
Chicago like the rest of his kind scooty
is a color-changing shape-shifting super
smart polymed
polymath now scientists have sequenced
the octopus genome on the search for
Clues to his
Brilliance the octopus genome is much
bigger than that of its cousins like
oysters or
clams it had been thought that this was
because of a duplication in the past
essentially doubling up their entire
genome we know this has happened in many
other large genomed groups like mammals
or fish but after sequencing scientists
found no evidence of genome duplication
at all in fact the octopus genome is
broadly similar to many of its
invertebrate cousins except that is for
a massive expansion in two particular
Gene families previously thought to only
be expanded in vertebrates but how do
these genes set scoote apart from a
clam the first expanded Gene family
codes for a type of cell Adan proteins
called
protocadherins vital in neuronal
development scooty has around half a
billion neurons throughout his body five
times more than a mouse this network of
neurons makes him about as smart as a
dog and lets him learn and remember
complicated tasks like unscrewing this
jar to reach the tasty crab inside not
bad for a glorified clam the second Gene
family codes for a type of protein
called C2 H2 zinc finger transcription
factors it's a complicated name but the
point is that hundreds of these
transcription factors were unique to the
octopus and they were selectively
expressed in the kinds of tissues that
make the octopus special things like
their suckers their neural tissue and
their skin ladened with color changing
cells it it appears that developments in
these genes could have been critical to
the evolution of the octopus's
incredible powers of camouflage
deception and
dexterity it is surprising that the
expansion of just two Gene families
could potentially have led to such
sophisticated intelligence and
morphology but then again scooty and
octopuses in general have never really
been fans of
[Music]
convention